the aquaman movie is finally on his way
to being a real thing the solo adventure
for the DC Comics character rolled out
its first full trailer and the result is
people feeling more excited than they
thought they could ever be over a
superhero who can talk to fish the
movie's long-awaited first trailer
provides the clearest look yet at what
we can expect from the murky depths here
are all the details you may have missed
from the first Aquaman movie trailer the
trench one of the trailers most exciting
shots involves Jason Momoa as Aquaman
and amber herds mera diving into the
ocean to escape a swarm of monsters this
evil group chasing after the Atlantean
heroes are members of a society known as
that the trench who were first
introduced in a 2011 Aquaman Comics run
by writer Jeff Jones who has a story
credit on the film formerly Atlanteans
themselves a trencher a splinter sect
that was formed when the legendary city
sank into the sea with their group
falling deep into the Marianas Trench
while the rest of the surviving Atlantis
population adapted to underwater sea
life and maintain the humanoid looks the
trench became monstrous and
cannibalistic adopting savage methods of
hunting and marauding in order to
survive led by their own king and queen
the trench serves as a dark mirror image
to the other prosperous Atlanteans sea
monsters who are some of the more
formidable dangers of the deep volcko
one shot of the trailer lingers on a
teenaged Aquaman or an Aqua Teen if you
will
training in the art of catching a spear
in between his hands a movie puts to
good use as an adult that training
sequence also offers a short glimpse of
Willem Dafoe's character volcko in
action according to Dafoe volcko is
essentially Arthur's mentor figure being
100% Atlantean while Arthur is half
human and was raised on the surface
their characters with a lot of comics
history together with volcko serving as
Arthur's Regent after he takes the
Atlantean throne swim gird a big moment
in the Aquaman trailer is his explosive
arrival on a submarine
delicious I'm a Warner but what you
might have missed as Aquaman's approach
to the submarine it only lasts about a
second and shows Aquaman super swimming
his way toward the sub a skill we
haven't really gotten to see him show
off in his earlier movie appearances
regardless it's a power he's long had in
the comics being able to swim at the
rate of six thousand eight hundred miles
per hour home invasion the other big
highlight of the trailer is Black Manta
or if you're not a longtime comics fan
the guy in the evil scuba suit beyond
having one of the coolest looks in the
entire history of comic book movies it
looks like the Aquaman rival will play a
part in some deeply personal drama in
the Jeff Jones comics from which Aquaman
partially takes inspiration Black Manta
gets hired by a doctor named Stephen
chin to acquire a blood sample from
Aquaman as a boy in a bid to prove that
he's something more than human
the pursuit ultimately results in the
hero's father's death in the trailer
black manta a scene in full combat mode
in the domestic location as the only
surface site household we see in the
trailer it's tempting to think that this
set piece takes place inside of the
lighthouse home of Aquaman's childhood
which would spell pretty terrible things
for the one non-superpowered member of
his family should black manta get his
hands on him unite the seven in addition
to giving audiences an idea of what
they're in for on their journey under
the sea with Aquaman and Friends the
Aquaman trailer finally gave moviegoers
an answer to a question that's been
lingering out there for years
specifically after all this time we
finally know the meaning of the phrase
unites the seven the very first image of
Jason Momoa as Aquaman came in February
2015 more than three years before his
solo movie's release dates that image
was superimposed with the phrase unite
the seven at the time and four years
later no one was really certain what
this phrase was meant to convey as it
turns out the tagline refers to what
appears to be the general plot of
Aquaman with Arthur's half-brother arm
working to unite the seven kingdoms of
the ocean into one unified force to take
on the surface world in all-out war and
I'm bringing
the seven seas with me just talk another
aspect of undersea living that a lot of
people don't think about is
communication
Justice League had mirrored user control
over water to create an air bubble for
the purposes of conversation luckily
that weird potentially drama crippling
solution isn't being brought over to
Aquaman solo Alton director James Wan
confirmed as much on Twitter writing
frettin are no air bubbles for dialogue
in my underwater world so how do they
talk in the water in Aquaman the answer
as the trailer confirms is that they
just can sometimes it's best not to
overthink things it was worst pep talk
ever
Nereus the trailer for Aquaman sets up a
lot about the movie even though it
doesn't linger too long on everything it
introduces one of those quick glimpses
appears to introduce Dolph Lundgren's
character Nereus we don't know much
about what Nereus will get up to in this
movie but we do know that he's been
substantially altered from his comic
book counterpart in at least one way in
the comics he and mirror were in a
relationship in the movie they evidently
father and daughter yellow eyes as
played by Jason Momoa the Aquaman of the
movies has typically been shown as
having some mystically pale eyes but one
pivotal moment to the Aquaman trailer
appears to be a whole new invention for
the character the yellow shade that
young Garth is eyes turn as he
communicates with a sea life in the
aquarium it'd be understandable to think
that those yellow eyes come straight
from the comic books but that doesn't
seem to be the case most likely it's a
movie invention meant solely for the
audience to understand when Arthur's
revving up to Fuhrer polish sharks at
his enemies